finalmente el acuerdo temporal entre la
oea agencia nuclear de la onu e irán es
una realidad tras una reunión de dos
días en teherán ambas partes acordaron
que el organismo podrá seguir
monitoreando el programa nuclear de irán
al menos durante tres meses se mantendrá
el mismo número de inspectores
sin embargo apoyados en una ley aprobada
recientemente irán suspenderá el llamado
protocolo adicional que permitía
inspecciones sorpresa a las
instalaciones nucleares
rafael grossi director de la hoya
lamentó esta decisión pero dijo que el
acuerdo pactado es razonable acordamos
que en vista de la ley y en particular
de la disposición que establece las
limitaciones alcanzamos un entendimiento
técnico bilateral temporal por el cual
la organización internacional de energía
atómica continuará con las actividades
de verificación y monitoreo necesarias
por un período de hasta tres meses
por su parte desde irán aseguraron que
el gobierno bloquearía el acceso de la
onu a las cámaras en sus instalaciones
nucleares respaldándose en la ley
nacional vivir
[Música]
la ley nos obliga a no facilitar las
cintas de esas cámaras a la oiea esa es
una decisión técnica no es una decisión
política yo no tomo esa decisión es a
nivel técnico pero la idea no obtendrá
las grabaciones de esas cámaras
fondos que con este movimiento irán
intenta presionar a la administración de
joe biden a volver al pacto nuclear de
2015 después de que el gobierno de
donald trump lo abandonara
unilateralmente en 2018 el ejecutivo de
vaivén ha manifestado que está abierto a
negociaciones pero solo sheeran deja de
incumplir los puntos del acuerdo nuclear
cosa que lleva haciendo gradualmente
desde 2018